britney spears says she has some self
work in her future today's a great day
[Music]
for britney spears
and it's a great day for justice
following the game-changing court ruling
last week suspending the pop icon's
father jamie spears as her conservator
brittany took to instagram to share what
lies ahead alongside this photo of a
large tree she wrote although there is
change and things to celebrate in my
life i still have a lot of healing to do
thankfully i have a good support system
and am taking time to understand it's
okay to slow down and breathe i just
want to be a happy person while
practicing some self-love britney also
says she plans to pray love and support
others in return if you had one word to
describe how brittany's feeling today
what do you think it is happy and this
tracks with what her attorney shared
after wednesday's major court ruling we
just saw her post on instagram she's
flying on a plane and she said she's on
cloud nine i can't say where she is but
she's in a much nicer place than this
and she is on cloud nine she of course
is engaged what does she want to do once
this conservative ship ends because you
fought so ferociously already to make
that happen well that's a good question
and what i would say to that is for the
first time in about 13 years
that decision will be up to brittany and
only brittany and that's a great thing
britney's positive mindset will
certainly be needed for the work that
lies ahead the singer still remains
under a conservatorship with a judge
appointing cpa john zabel as jaime's
temporary replacement we're focused on
financial misconduct by jamie spears and
we're going to uncover all of the facts
and see where they take us whether jaime
is going to be permanently removed will
be decided at a future court hearing on
thursday jamie spears issued this
statement via his attorney mr spears
loves his daughter brittany
unconditionally for 13 years he has
tried to do what is in her best interest
whether a conservator or her father i
think the support of the free brittany
movement has been instrumental
and to the extent that
it allowed my firm to carry the ball
across the finish line i thank them as
well according to rosengar he hopes to
have brittany free from her
conservatorship soon and potentially
before a milestone occasion this
december will this wrap up by her 40th
birthday do you think that's the goal
meanwhile brittany celebrated the court
decision by heading to the beach
[Music]
she and fiance sam skari's island
getaway was well documented on social
media including these nazi for work
picks which required a handful of
strategically placed emojis as rosengard
told the crowd of britney supporters and
media outlets last week his client has
every reason to celebrate jamie spears
has been suspended
and he will be formally removed shortly
jamie spears and others
are going to face even more serious
ramifications
for his misconduct
i said at the outset that my firm and i
were going to take
a top to bottom look at what jamie
spears
and his representatives have done here
that's already in process
and it will continue for as long as it
can possibly do that
to get justice for brittany
[Music]
you